For two to the power of X, the slope is below one. You can see that by connecting this point and that point.
The curve passes through X equals zero, Y equals one, and X equals one, Y equals two,
and the same is true for this line with a slope of one. Obviously, our power function, two to the power of X,
makes a left turn. If it hits this straight line in these red spots, it has to dive below that red line.
Meaning that its slope at x equals zero is less than the slope of the red line.
Less than one. The slope of three to the power of X at X equals zero is larger than one.
Let me add this straight line again that has a slope of one and a Y intercept of one.
And if you look really closely, you'll see that this exponential function, three to the power of X and this red line
intersect at two points. The first intersection being close to X equals -.17. This means that the blue curve dives
below the red line on the left-hand side, meaning that it has to have a slope that is larger than one.